if you're still planning on where you
will watch and celebrate the big game
this sunday louis caputo from rosina
after venetian is here to help so don't
you fret we got you we've got drinks
we've got food the venetian has so many
options to eat and drink i love it there
so let's just talk big game specials
first thank you very much for having me
i'm very excited to be here today
and very excited to go over the big game
specials that we have at the venetian
the long run down it's going to be a
long run down but a fun run down
so we have various different
venues within the cocktail collective
we have elektra dorsey and rocina
so if we're going to talk big game let's
talk elektra first okay elektra has
a 40-foot digital screen so it's
literally from wall to wall
70 million pixels wow so i've seen games
in there it's like being at the game
it's literally on the field
it's amazing wow
it's one of the most fantastic places to
see a game i've seen games there it's
tremendous okay and that's elektra
that's electric so let's talk because i
know this drink that you're making is
also at elektra so that's correct what
are we making okay so we're making a
drink called the spicy tommy now you can
make this at home but i suggest you get
it at elektra and have one of us make it
okay so the spicy tommy starts with
one ounce of lime okay
you may please start a sauce please okay
i would rather you do it one ounce oh
am i there
a little more a little more
oh you're good boom
like a pro mixologist
so you can do one ounce of lime
then you're gonna do
three ounces
[Music]
of agave syrup okay
you're going to do two ounces okay of
blanco tequila
quite delicious let's get it going get
it started and what's the vibe like when
you as you as you're making the drink
what's the vibe like it is
and all we do at venetian is when we go
big we party at all three venues rosina
dorsey and elektra i love it so then you
get it ready
you gotta think
you got to shake it like you got
something going on love it
so then
you pour
that's looking quite delicious
am i getting ready for it what kind of
flavors am i getting right now i'm to
say i got one more thing to add though
so yeah get a good whiff i have one more
thing to do there's another step that's
all right no no oh this is an image this
is this this is everything i love it i
love it okay we have 30 seconds we have
30 seconds tell everybody about the
packages that people can get so the
various different packages you can get
we're going to have different bottle
services so you're going to be able to
pick different liquor
bottles
different beer
energy drinks water okay now rossina and
electra are going to have food
by moon palace which is by celebrity
chef david chang and if you go to dorsey
another one of our fantastic venues at
the venetian resort we're going to have
food from lorena garcia and chica
fantastic you can there's no better
place to see the game
than at the cocktail collective in the
venetian resort i love you you literally
can walk into the venetian all of sunday
and have somewhere to go pretty much
that's accurate come see me come see me
at rocina we'll take good care of you
well cheers because this drink is good
i will send it to you